Anthony blinken llegó a Jetta con una
gran tarea reparar las relaciones con
Arabia Saudita y los temas de
desacuerdos son numerosos Es sobre todo
el histórico acercamiento entre riad y
tejerán que impone un nuevo orden
geopolítico en la región que preocupa a
Washington en su primera reunión el
martes el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense abordó con mohamedman la
cuestión de los Derechos Humanos una
conversación abierta y sincera según los
responsable estadounidense otro tema
abordado La Guerra Civil en Sudán donde
los saudíes y estadounidenses han sido
incapaces de lograr una tregua duradera
Aunque Estados Unidos se ha declarado
dispuesto a reanudar las conversaciones
con los enviados de ambas partes
Esta visita de blinquen es también una
oportunidad para abogar por la
normalización de las relaciones entre
arabias Saudita e Israel el precio del
petróleo figuró entre los temas
delicados que fueron abordados las
autoridades saudíes prevén a recortar la
producción en julio un millón de
barriles menos al día para que suba el
precio del crudo una medida que podría
tener repercusiones sobre los costos
para los consumidores y sobre todo la
inflación glo